il se veut le chantre de la droite
décomplexée au risque d'être critiqué
sinon rejeté désormais par une partie de
son camp jean françois copé invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous l'ump qui se divise
donc la compétition pour sa présidence
et bien nous en parlerons dans un quart
d'heure avec frédéric dumoulin de l'
agence france-presse notre partenaire et
puis perrine tarneaud nous rejoindra et
vous interrogera sur les passages les
plus personnelles de votre livre
programme donc pas celle sur le racisme
anti blanc ou bien le sort subi par
certains enfants durant le ramadhan 1
mais n'est pas ce qui concerne notamment
votre histoire familiale
les téléspectateurs réagissent c'est
posent leurs questions par le biais de
l'application tilly tchèque d'orange
notre autre partenaire les attaques
contre l'exécutif d'abord si vous voulez
bien
jean françois copé je parle d' attaque
car là je constate que les mots sont de
plus en plus fort le mot imposture par
exemple est sorti de votre bouche
puisque vous condamner par avance le
chef de l'état et son premier ministre
ou est-ce l'un des effets là encore
peut-être collatéral de la campagne
interne à l'ump a mais ça n'a rien à
voir avec la campagne de l'ump je crois
que en cinq mois
les français sont en train d'ouvrir les
yeux sur ce que nous avions et ou en
particulier avec mes amis dénoncer tout
au long de la campagne fond de françois
hollande s'est fait élire sur une
imposture
il a fait croire aux français que
l'essentiel des malheurs notre pays
venait de ce que nicolas sarkozy était à
la tête du pays et il a fait croire que
pour ce qui le concernait il ne l'est
pas augmenter les impôts et qu'il allait
en réalité faire ce que nous ne faisions
pas qu'on a un agent tu as des courses
qu'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui on voit
qu'il a systématiquement supprimés
toutes les mesures excellente que nous
avions pris je pense en particulier à la
détaxation des heures supplémentaires
pour les gens qui a du coup
malheureusement ne peuvent plus
maintenant gagner plus en travaillant
plus ou bien encore en supprimant les
allègements de charges patronales contre
l'entente un bosquet on entend critique
remise en cause des capacités des
compétences presque de la légitimité du
pouvoir et nano n'y en aura coûté non
légitimité la question la légitimité ne
se pose pas ya sur le suffrage universel
s'est exprimée en revanche pour le reste
oui bien sûr qu'il ya eu mensonge mais
enfin écoutez ya pas de doute là dessus
vous ou vous avez entendu vous monsieur
hollande annoncé qu'il allait augmenter
de 30 milliards d'euros les impôts en
quatre mois pour matraquer fiscalement
la totalité des français
puis les mensonges ont continué après il
ya encore quinze jours et jean marc
ayrault à la télévision annonce sans
rire que neuf français sur dix ne seront
pas concernés par les hausses d'impôts
vous avez pu constater en tant que
journalistes qu'il avait fait ce qu'on
appelle un mensonge d'état devant des
millions de français
qu'est ce qui se passe la conséquence de
tout ça c'est quoi en quatre mois
c'est toute l'économie française qui est
paralysée moi je peux en témoigner un
mot la ville dont je suis maire je
rencontre un entrepreneur un artisan un
commerçant un ménage tous me disent on
bouge plus on y prennent pas en consomme
pas on n'investit pas on n'embauche pas
quand la réalité du pouvoir ne
correspond pas aux promesses électorales
vous parlez d'un mensonge d'état des
dons il y en a eu des mensonges d'état
sans doute tous les régimes vont
peut-être enfin jusqu'à un certain point
moi j'ai pas le souvenir que nous
n'avons pas mis en oeuvre les promesses
que nous avions présenté aux français en
2007 par exemple rappelez-vous nous
avions dit très clairement que nous
allions détaxer les heures
supplémentaires nous l'avons fait nous
avions dit très clairement nous allions
supprimé les droits de succession nous
l'avons fait les socialistes d'ailleurs
l'ont immédiatement les ont
immédiatement remis nous avons dit que
nous allions autant que possible libérer
l'économie autant qu'on le pouvait on
l'a fait nous allons rien faire face à
des crises successives très douloureuse
je constate aujourd'hui que nous avons
un gouvernement totalement perdue avec
une absence totale de cap stratégique
alors que je reste pas moins qu'ils
disent regardez les les enquêtes
d'opinion regarder l'état des français
aujourd'hui il ya plus une décision
économique est prise dans tous les cas
le pouvoir dit qu'il fait un certain
nombre de choses qu'il a annoncé on va
en parler un peu plus tard si vous
voulez bien jean françois copé mais on a
l'impression quand même que le sentiment
d'unité nationale qui a été évoqué tout
au long du week-end par vous même un
banc sous les responsables politiques
sur la question des gens du terrain est
loin d adriano les sur la question de la
lutte contre le terrorisme
il faut qu est pas dans ma et là dessus
je les dis tout de suite il est évident
que face à une situation comme celle qui
consiste à lutter de toutes nos forces
contre le terrorisme nous devons être
totalement rassemblée
j'aurais aimé d'ailleurs la même unité
nationale lorsqu'elle est arrivée la
tragédie de montauban et de toulouse
vous souvenez
que les socialistes en pleine campagne
avait tenté de mettre en cause nos
services qui avait pourtant fait un
travail examen difficile jean narration
période par exemple ce mardi
solennellement à l'issue d'un entretien
avec les ministres de la justice de
l'intérieur rappelle sa détermination à
lutter contre le terrorisme et le
racisme là vous dites oui bien sûr la
maman a non seulement on lit mais on dit
à cela selon le dire et là la force de
conviction pour être bas que j'écoute et
je le souhaite parce que comme n'associe
absolument jamais l'opposition à rien
j'ose espérer qu'il le prend bien toutes
les bonnes décisions en tout cas il sait
je le lui ai dit c'est mon rôle de les
responsables du premier parti politique
d'opposition que sur ce sujet il y aura
toujours un rassemblement total en même
temps puisque vous m'interrogez sur ce
sujet et que vous avez noté que monsieur
valls faisait un lien entre les actions
terroristes et risques d'actions
terroristes et la délinquance que l'on
peut observer dans un certain nombre de
quartiers l'un étant lié à l'autre mais
l'autre n'étant pas heureusement
systématiquement liés alain
permettez-moi de m'inquiéter quand même
de voir que dans l'âme dans le travail
gouvernemental du moment il ya un
ministre de la justice qui est en train
de supprimer par la loi les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs délinquants
de supprimer les peines planchers de
supprimer le programme de construction
de places de prison et 2 revenant sur
les centres éducatifs fermés les oignons
construit les prisons elles sont sans
accusation voulez vous bien sûr on dit
que c'est justement là que se développe
la ri à la radicalisation de certains
noms là mais en tout cas ça raison de l'
année de droit commun alors vous êtes
d'accord avec avec c'est d'abord ceux de
coude et c'est un constat qui se prépare
par des études qui se la prison faut
d'abord les unes l'accusé
et on voit bien derrière tout cela qu'il
ya une politique pénitentiaire à
poursuivre c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous souvenez sans doute que nicolas
sarkozy s'était engagé dans sa campagne
à la construction de vingt mille places
de prison supplémentaires le programme a
été immédiatement interrompu c'est une
des premières décisions qui ont été
prises par les socialistes en arrivant
et tout faire pour que les détenus ne
bascule pas dans l'islamisme radical en
prison ben oui mais la plupart du temps
c'est lié à des situations qui sont
celles de nos prisons aujourd'hui vous
savez que nous avons malheureusement un
problème de surpopulation carcérale et
que là où nous nous disons la réponse
c'est des constructions de places de
prison les socialistes disent il faut
les remettre en liberté est la réception
des peines de prison inférieures à deux
ans la france appelle des alternatives à
la prison justement oui sans doute
enfin il ya aussi une organisation même
du du milieu pénitentiaire sur lequel il
ya des personnels qui font un travail
fantastique je peux en témoigner puisque
j'ai moi même ma circonscription
un centre pénitentiaire qui fonctionne
le mieux qu'il peut avec des équipes qui
sont très remarquable mais enfin il y a
la difficulté que vous évoquez est ce
que vous approuvez l'équation du
président du crif islam radical égale
nazisme déjeuner pour tout vous dire je
n'ai pas entendu donc je peux pas la
commenter ce qu'il a l'air moi-même
pardon vous me prenez un peu de
curiosité pas vu cette déclaration il
faut tout vérifier sur ces petits là
dessus les choses sont très claires
oui je le suis comme je crois tous les
français quelle que soit leur
sensibilité quelle que soit leur
religion quelles que soient leurs
convictions philosophico politique
totalement engagé dans la lutte contre
toutes ses formes d'extrémisme que je
dénonce d'ailleurs dans mon livre on
manifeste pour une droite décomplexée et
pour lequel il y a des propositions que
je formule parce que c'est un sujet
majeur et qui commence par une lutte
sans faille contre ce qu'on appelle le
communautarisme et face auquel françois
hollande un certain nombre de ses amis
ont fait oeuvre de certaines faiblesses
marque renault brille par exemple a
ouvert des créneaux spécifiques pour les
femmes dans certaines piscines de
certains quartiers de lille pendant près
de 70 toute impunité médiatique
intellectuelle je me permets de dire que
c'est un vrai sujet alors extrêmement
choquant je vous parlais du président du
crif mais pas entendu sa déclaration sur
le nazisme
hier le président du consistoire joël
mergui qui lui a appelé la communauté
musulmane dans son ensemble à se
ressaisir
est-ce que vous pensez que cet appel est
ronde et
témoin j'ai pardon ne m'en veuillez pas
là pour faire des commentaires et
commentaires la seule chose que je
puisse dire c'est que la mobilisation
contre toutes les formes de racisme
d'antisémitisme de xénophobie doit être
une mobilisation totale et sans faille
et sur ce point vous le savez peut-être
j'ai toujours toujours été constant dans
un appel à l'âme être alors seulement un
plaquage sur ces questions
l'application du programme de françois
hollande le chef de l'état a détaillé ce
bien son programme pour refonder l'école
vous même dans votre livre
oui je prenais une révolution scolaire
le fenouil opération veut aussi changer
l'école réforme des rythmes disparition
de certaines notations accablantes pour
certains élèves des notes qui sanctionne
dit-il suppression du redoublement est
ce que ça va dans le bon sens c'est ce
que se souvient des bonnes choses
non c'est exactement la liste de tout ce
qu'on ne souhaitait pas qu'il proposera
donc je suis désolé mais là on est
vraiment enfin moi je suis extrêmement
inquiet questions scolaires est une
question majeure pour notre société sur
laquelle titre personnel comme d'autres
j'ai beaucoup travaillé ces dernières
années
je ne retrouve évidemment rien de ses
propositions dans le programme de
françois hollande de quoi s'agit-il les
rythmes scolaires en gros rythme
scolaire il s'agit juste de décaler
quelques quelques éléments de la semaine
on revient donc c'est un éternel adjoint
voilà quelques jours et demi au lieu de
quatre jours très bien c'est un débat
éternel je veux juste appeler
l'attention sur une chose que françois
hollande s'est bien gardé de dire c'est
que c'est les communes qui vont devoir
payer les collectivités locales n'ont
pas le premier euro pour le faire et à
partir du moment où elles n'ont pas les
moyens de payer
françois hollande va se trouver dans un
déni de 2,2 pour mettre en oeuvre cette
réforme car la constitution est très
claire là dessus quand on transfère des
compétences on doit donner l'argent qui
va avec
première faiblesse de son raisonnement
deuxième faiblesse du raisonnement c'est
que c'est pour une réforme structurelle
ça qu'est ce qu'on attendait du
programme d'aujourd'hui par exemple que
l'on met la question de l'évaluation des
savoirs fondamentaux à l'entrée en
sixième en haut du podium
il ya aujourd'hui une préoccupation pour
tous ces enfants qui vont rentrer dans
l'univers impitoyable du collège en
passant venant du cm2 sans savoir lire
écrire et compter correctement ce une
priorité absolue j'ai recommandé une
évaluation à l'entrée en sixième elle
n'est toujours pas fait
deuxième exemple je préconise que le
chef de l'établissement soit le vrai
patron de son établissement qui puisse
choisir c
pédagogique et qu'ils puissent adapter
son projet c'est pas la même chose dans
le centre ville de meaux ou dans un
quartier sensible de tel ou tel de telle
ou telle ville rien à récupérer dans ce
cas d enseigner la morale
on en a parlé un instant face aux
dérives de la société enseigné la morale
laïque ça c'est une mesure que wave mais
je demande juste à vérifier ce qu'ils
meurent parce que si morale laïque ça
veut dire qu'on doit dire du mal des
religions c'est qu'on n'a rien compris
parce que l'objectif c'est lutter contre
l'ignorance d'idées j'ai entendu de
rappeler les valeurs de la république
oui c'est bien tant mieux rappeler les
bords de la république c'est très bien
il faut pas craindre non plus d'ailleurs
de s'occuper aussi de la responsabilité
des parents quand les enfants sont
défaillants j'ai dans ma propre vie la
mort un problème majeur avec une école
primaire dans lequel il se trouve qu'un
certain nombre d'enfants sont absolument
un comportement inacceptable
avec des parents qui aujourd'hui ne font
pas correctement géré n'accomplissent
pas leur mission de parents qui est
acceptable n être reçu par les
professeurs ça ne peut pas continuer
comme ça je rappelle que nous avions mis
en place par exemple une loi pour lutter
contre l'absentéisme scolaire
la première décision était de la
supprimer alors qu'elle mettait en cause
la responsabilité parentale
je pense qu'encore une fois françois
hollande avance avec l'idéologique
moteur ce qui est une manière de
faciliter l élite de ce métal avec les
camarades syndiqués rien je trouve ça
dommage
ils sont dans la rue vous avez eu la cgt
aujourd'hui oui pas pour les mêmes
raisons mais en revanche du côté de
l'éducation nationale tout va très très
bien quels ont été les deux grandes
décisions françois hollande voulait dit
si t'es pas je vais les cités la
première c'est le temps passé des
recrutements massifs sans jamais
démontrer qu'on en a besoin et on n'a
pas le premier euro pour les payer et la
deuxième décision s'est rajouté quatre
jours de vacances supplémentaires à la
toussaint c'est un peu c'est méconnaître
la réalité des familles d'aujourd'hui
voilà quand on sait la difficulté que
nous avons aujourd'hui que beaucoup de
familles ont aujourd'hui à occuper les
enfants pendant les vacances alors rien
à sauver à part le traité budgétaire
européen mais les nouveautés bien sûr
est ce que quand même vous apprécier à
leur juste valeur les efforts du premier
ministre du président de la république
pour rassembler ni l'anglais qui font ce
que le maximum de députés socialistes
sur un texte fort heureux sait déjà
c'est ridicule comme ça
la vérité c'est que françois hollande
dans la catégorie des impostures dont je
parlais tout à l'heure a quand même fait
campagne pendant six mois en disant si
vous m'élisez présence d'un public pas
de tête européen parce que je négocierai
celui qui a été
décidée avec entre nicolas sarkozy
angela merkel et l'ensemble de nos
partenaires européens
bon bah il est élu on a perdu quatre
mois et puis on revient au traité
initial voilà donc c'est une de ces
impostures supplémentaires que l'on peut
mettre à la liste de la campagne
électorale de françois hollande ce qui
d'ailleurs est assez amusant c'est que
tout le monde tombe sur les verts qui
veulent pas le voter les communistes qui
veulent pas voter
je veux quand même rappeler que eux ils
sont cohérents avec les engagements de
françois hollande quoi c'est lui qui ne
l'est pas après ça pose un problème de
cohésion gouvernementale
et comme vous l'avez vu france jean marc
ayrault avec la l'autorité qui est la
sienne a dit ça ne se passera pas comme
ça
il a gardé les ministres verts bien sûr
alors vous refusez le politiquement
correct la bien pensante jean françois
copé vous l'écrivez au fil des pages de
votre livre programme donc
mais c'est moins aujourd'hui le fonds
des arguments que vous avancez que
peut-être le style qui suscite des
remous y compris au sein de votre camp
je vous le disais là je parle du pain au
chocolat bien sûr ou bien au racisme
anti blanc certains de vos amis
d'ailleurs sont éloignés de vous sur ces
questions fondamentales selon vous vous
lui mettez en avant jour après jour dans
tous les meetings avec un certain succès
vous allez pouvoir vous en parler mais
avant d'accueillir frédéric dumoulin
d'une agence france presse
sur ces questions là et sur votre
campagne à droite tous on retrouve le
reportage de florence maurice l'un se
pose en rassembleur
l'autre est entrés en croisade racisme
anti-blanc histoire du pain au chocolat
jean françois copé veut briser les
tabous champion autoproclamé d'une
droite décomplexée
en meeting ces déclarations font
exploser l'applaudimètre mais au sein de
la droite ses anciens alliés ne ménagent
pas leurs coûts nous n'avons pas aller
sur ce terrain là ce ne sont pas nos
mots ce n'est pas notre dictionnaire et
j'ajoute que ça nous a fait mais
j'ajoute ce sont des discours de
minoritaires qu'on doit rassembler tous
ses discours ses petites phrases sont
toxiques elles sont dangereuses
elle reconnaît elle altère le pacte
républicain et j'ajoute c'est une erreur
d'analysé donc naturellement je partage
pas l'analyse de jean françois dans le
rétroviseur de jean françois copé il y à
nicolas sarkozy et sa campagne offensive
de l'entre-deux tours qui lui aurait
fait grignoter quelques points alors
comme lui jean françois copé se pose en
challenger revendique le terrain et
fustige l'élite bien pensante le voit là
même qui s'affiche aux côtés de nicolas
sarkozy sur sa profession de foi
et qui selon le journal le parisien
travaillerait avec patrick buisson
le père de la stratégie très droitière
de nicolas sarkozy la logique des
campagnes électorales c'est qu'on leur
cherche à se distinguer de son
partenaire de son adversaire et qu'on
ait conduit à durcir le ton et ça je
crois que ça ne va pas dans la bonne
direction et en général je n'ai pas
l'habitude de soutenir des choses qui ne
vont pas dans la bonne direction mais
les foudres des sages de l'ump importe
peu à jean françois copé car sa cible
dans un scrutin interne est tout autre
ce sont les adhérents du parti qu'il
doit convaincre des militants
traditionnellement plus à droite que les
sympathisants
ces quelques critiques du politiquement
correct nous sommes dans la droite
républicaine et le centre c'est ça qui a
formé l'ump et nous continuons dans
cette tradition simple stratégie
électorale ou véritable durcissement
idéologique
difficile à dire dans l'autre camp
pendant ce temps là françois fillon se
pose en rassembleur un candidat normal
en quelque sorte sa faveur jour vos
questions à jean françois copé sur cette
compétition acharnée aux fans rim perd
un peu plus de cinq semaines de
l'élection maintenant on voit que les
fondations sont plutôt défavorables les
assauts l'ump sont majoritairement pour
françois fillon
qu'est ce qui fait que vous y croyez
encore au fond mais mille raisons mille
raisons en fait en vérité ces sondages
n'ont absolument aucun sens c'est bien
de les publier ça permet à chacun de
d'alimenter le débat et les pronostics
mais enfin il ya quand même quelque
chose qui ne colle pas tout à fait les
sons sont des gens qu'on appelle des
sympathisants devient un échantillon de
12 millions de français alors que ceux
qui vont voter c'est 260 milles ce sont
260 mille militants qui eux sont membres
de l'ump qui portent l'ump avec lesquels
j'ai le positionnement avec les autres
gérants
j'ai construit une relation notamment
l'occasion de cette campagne
présidentielle que je dirais personne ne
pourra jamais nous enlever c'est une
relation de deux d'engagement d'émotion
de fraternité d'armes si je puis me
permettre ce terme à travers le combat
que nous avons mené ensemble pour
soutenir nicolas sarkozy alors visite à
la monsieur grossier arabe
même dans votre propre quand vous êtes
critiqué confondues oui mais vous n'avez
actif comme si je peux me permettre à
paris de certains ténors
ben oui enfin disons que vous avez
présenté les choses d'une manière qui
pourrait correspondre la thèse que vous
défendiez soyons justes jusqu'au bout
non non rien en défense non mais que
vous défendiez dans votre reportage nos
méthodes et ne prenez pas mal c'est
juste pour nous rien simplement de
donner mon point de vue j'aurais pu vous
donner des noms on avait parlé de
dizaines de préciser des ténors des
barytons des sopranos de l'ump qui vous
aurait dit qu élu de terrain aux côtés
des militants il trouvait très bien
qu'ils se lèvent un homme pour comment
dire penser que l'avenir la droite
n'était pas dans le dans la droite
complexé mais plutôt dans celles qui
assument une réalité du quotidien que la
thèse que je défends c'est que nous qui
sommes vous le savez et moi le premier
d'ailleurs alain juppé vous n'avez pas
passé ce passage c'est dommage lana
juppé lui-même qui n'est pas fait pour
l'indulgence et qui a dit que j'étais
irréprochable sur la question du refus
de l'alliance avec le front national
la thèse que je défends depuis toujours
et la suivante et c'est le maire de
meaux qui le dit c'est d'être et bien
entendu proposé à toute alliance avec le
front national
mais en même temps à attendre la
deuxième joue à ne pas tomber dans le
piège tendu depuis des années des années
par françois mitterrand et jean marie le
pen est repris par son fils spirituel
françois hollande avec madame le pen
c'est donc dire ce que les français
ressentent comme exaspération comme
souffrances et d'apporter une solution
il noie dans mon livre j'apporte sur
tous ces sujets de très nombreuses
solutions ceux du avec monsieur fillon
en fait il est souvent perçu comme un
combat des chefs
et vous vous diriez cas vraiment vous
estimez qu'il ya vraiment une divergence
idéologique entre vous deux écoutez
honda borges les commentaires si je peux
me permettre ont évolué on ne dit plus
c'est ce que c'est simplement un combat
des chefs
on dit on dit quoi aujourd'hui on dit
aussi que cette deux lignes
dix teintes qui sont des lignes
d'ailleurs qu'ils ne s'opposent pas
forcément qu'ils sont complémentaires au
sein de l'ump
la ligne que je défends c'est celle
d'une droite et d'un centre droite
décomplexée c'est à dire républicain
mais également moderne ouvert aux
grandes questions de ce monde à la
compétitivité de nos entreprises de à la
question de la modernisation de l'état à
la baisse des déficits mais aussi mais
aussi à combattre le politiquement
correct de la gamme étant encore là de
la droite complexe et un vous faites là
le portrait en creux et françois fillon
voient c'est bah je sais pas mais en
tout cas je fais ce sont des projets
musclées pour faire évidemment
apparaître votre rival comme un mou non
non non non écouter fossat je vous
laisse aux clubs d'acquisition dans vos
propos non prenons les sujets peut-être
un peu différemment
prenons des exemples concrets parce que
je crois que c'est aussi ça l'intérêt
lorsque j'ai évoqué la question de mon
engagement contre toutes les formes de
racisme et que j'ai évoqué la question
parmi ces combats à mener contre le
racisme de raciste qui était particulier
tous et si condamnable que les autres
qui était ce que j'avais le raciste en
disant que cette idée qu'ils aient des
quartiers où il ne fait pas bon être une
femme ou être de couleur blanche bon que
ses souffrances au quotidien je les ai
vus entendus en tant que maire d'une
ville qui n'est pas une ville je dirais
qu'ils allaient même protection que
certains autres quartiers de france par
exemple au centre de paris
j'ai prié j'ai pris une décision cette
décision si de le dire
alors on met tous on m'est tombé dessus
tout les socialistes toute la gauche
bien pensante à procès en bo1
droitisation oui oui mais ça se connaît
ce discours là ça n'a rien de deux de
plus ou moins droite c'est l'observation
d'une réalité
je note que personne je dis bien
personne de ceux qui ont pris la parole
y compris pour vociférer je pense à sos
racisme n'a nié ce fait que je dénonçais
et pour cause madame belkacem a fait
pareil monsieur valls qui parle
aujourd'hui des rappeurs l'a fait en son
temps
simplement la question que je pose à
tout le monde est la suivante belhoste
puisqu'on est d'accord sur le fait que
ça existe et que je propose des
solutions pour le combattre est ce qu'on
doit se taire c'est ça la question
et ma réponse c'est qu'on ne doit pas se
taire on doit le dire et proposer des
solutions
si on ne le fait pas ce sera simplement
les extrêmes de
cette droite qui feront c'est à dire
monsieur mélenchon à côté madame le pen
de l'autre et comme nous avons refusé
l'alliance avec le front national
alors il faut dire l'échangé vous
répondez quoi monsieur baroin qui lui
justement outre le fait qu'ils trouvent
que c'est de ces propos sont toxiques
il dit en fait que vous faites une
erreur d analyse c'est à dire que franck
que nicolas sarkozy n'est pas remonté en
toute fin de campagne
grâce à cette pseudo droitisation mais
peu mais pour d'autres raisons donc à
vous et vous voulez savoir quoi ce que
je réponds à françois marié baroin on la
suit sur ce fait pas les solutions mais
là dessus j'ai rien à répondre françois
est maintenant très engagé aux côtés de
françois fillon et j'imagine prêt à
construire reconstruire déconstruire des
arguments dans tous les sens pour voilà
donner du contenu à son engagement pour
françois fillon je n'ai donc pas de
réponse à faire sur le fond j'ai compris
qu'il était donc en désaccord avec le
fait qu'on dise la vérité sur lequel est
sur le terrain et qu'il était donc en
désaccord avec le fait qu'on puisse
proposer des solutions
c'est son choix pour tout vous dire je
ne le reconnais pas complètement sur le
racisme anti-blanc certains vous avez
même sorti des témoignages de gauche
ancien aller dans votre sens mort dont
je suis reçue sur le petit pain au
chocolat
c'est con à rassurer l'enfant pendant la
période de ramadan là et c'est très
grave et très content et au projet du
tout mais mais j'ai beaucoup de ces
mordus tout contester ça a été
exactement le même processus
le même c'est à dire que personne n'a
contesté les faits personne vous pouvez
regarder personne mais monsieur ayrault
qui nous faire la leçon
chez vos confrères de france inter le
dimanche matin j'ai été amené à lui
répond dans un meeting quelques heures
après est venu dire oui ces phénomènes
peuvent exister mais heureusement qu'il
l'a reconnu puisque tout le monde le
sait c'est du même acabit que ce
restaurateur de marseille passé à tabac
pendant l'été parce qu'il avait le
malheur de servir des repas pendant la
journée passée à tabac
c'est dans la presse ont la vérité qui a
derrière tout cela c'est quoi c'est que
pendant le monsieur ayrault finalement
ne nie pas que ces faits existent eh
bien nous retombons sur le même problème
que ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
pour le racisme anti blanc faut-il ou
non le dire
et encore une fois je le répète ici on
le dénonce comme je le fais en tant que
républicain c'est proposer des solutions
la solution elle existe elle est dans la
ghettoïsation je les fais à meaux en
cassant les tours en mettant à la place
des immeubles de quatre étages à taille
humaine un mix en accession à la
propriété et logement social là où il
n'y avait que des logements sociaux en
mettant des caméras vidéo surveillance
des policiers municipaux une zone
franche pour détaxer les entreprises qui
embauchent les gens du quartier
en mettant la culture du sport et de la
g300 s est bien qu'est ce qui se passe à
la fin vous n'avez plus le même quartier
donc au lieu de d'interdire la parole et
les témoignages de gens qui comme moi
veulent reconstruire la droite et le
centre droit de demain en disant les
choses en proposant des solutions
on est dans une logique de dire non il
faut lui interdire de parler c'est
tellement mieux qu'ils parlent pas assez
on est on à un bonbon pour certains mots
codés
c'est le mot droitisation dire que celui
qui dit la vérité que des propositions
non c'est juste parce qu'il est temps
droitisation en campagne comme vous
disiez tout à l'heure mais quand on dit
rien et bien moi je vais vous dire dans
cette affaire là monde est mon arbitrage
il est rendu depuis bien longtemps
parce que celui dont je pense que le la
ville dont je suis l'élu elle sait ce
que c'est au quotidien la souffrance
quelle que soit d'ailleurs les origines
les sensibilités il avant l'heure de
pointe et que la réponse soit c'est une
réponse c'est une réponse
assumez vous avez encore des tableaux
guillemets à combattre enfin écoutés
mais après le après le pain au chocolat
le racisme anti blanc il ya d'autres
choses qui s'est excusé moi je ne
prenais pas en mauvaise part mais cette
manie qu'ont à paris mais ça s'est
tellement c'est tellement parisien de
vouloir absolument nous faire des procès
en sincérité des hommes politiques
pourquoi est ce que là le la seule
explication qu'on pourrait donner au
fait que je parle de tout ça dans un
livre c'est que je suis en campagne pour
l'ump mais ça fait des années que je le
dis des années que je le raconte en 1999
j'écrivais un livre puisque je n'ai pas
appris à l'ena où je raconte mon
parcours de mère m'a découverte de
jeunes mères qui voit ce qu'est la
réalité du quotidien
hélas ces quinze ans après je dis qu'on
a fait on a apporté des réponses et qu
on y est arrivé donc plutôt que de dire
oh boy fait ça parce qu'il était en
campagne
est ce que une fois on peut accepter que
les hommes politiques soient sincères
dans ce qu'il dit on sait que vous
parlez souvent à nicolas sarkozy est ce
que vous avez l'occasion depuis cette
polémique
de lui en parler puisque lui aussi
pendant la campagne présidentielle
s'était vu reprocher d'aller trop vers
la droite
donc est-ce que vous en avez parler ou
pas enfin pas spécialement mais encore
une fois cette histoire de dettes trop
vers la droite ou vers la gauche ça veut
dire écoutez on va y aller à l'envers ça
veut donc dire que si on ne voit pas le
problème est que si d'autres banques
n'acceptent pas de le dénoncer
donc on va vers la gauche donc on est
dans la gauchisation donc ne vous me
demander d'arbitrer entre droitisation
et gauchisation vous voyez comme tout ce
pardon ne prenez pas mal évolué comme
tout ça est absurde
le vrai débat il est de savoir face à
cette vérité est ce qu'on a le courage
de dire des choses ou de ne pas les dire
et pour ce qui me concerne je ne cadrais
jamais et personne je le dis très
amicalement personne ne m'empêchera de
dire ce que les uns et les autres de nos
compatriotes 10 et nous demandent de
résoudre
sinon je serais à la place aux extrêmes
et tous ceux qui me font ce petit procès
sympathique la droite droitisation etc
il oublie juste un petit détail sexy
front national est seul à parler de ces
questions sans apporter de réponse et en
stigmatisant nous tomberons nous tombera
recouvre les vikings ne le croit vous
pensez que ce meilleur rempart face au
front national de c'est le meilleur
rempart et une face au front national
et face à cette collusion que tout le
monde connaît entre la gauche et
l'extrême droite
parce que eux sont totalement rassemblée
1e ils ont fait une alliance sans se
poser aucune question avec l'extrême
gauche de mélenchon qui n'a rien à
envier à l'extrême droite de la marie le
pen et nous on a dit notre honneur c'est
de ne pas faire d'alliance avec
l'extrême droite
mais en contrepartie je le dis jamais je
ne demanderai à mes zano électeurs à nos
militants de voter pour le parti
socialiste allié l'extrême gauche car
cette espèce de pseudo front républicain
n'est absolument pas une réalité
politique
c'est simplement une manière pour garder
le pouvoir à n'importe quel prix
aujourd'hui manière de voir les jeux
marine le pen envisage des accords aux
municipales un elle sait que la base de
l'ump vous le savez une partie des élus
ils sont favorables pour sauver une
mairie vous me développement les choses
sont très claires elles le sont
d'ailleurs pour toute notre famille
politique il n'y aura pas d'alliance
électorale avec le front national
dernière question frédéric tellement
parlé nicolas sarkozy en fait on voit
que vous faites beaucoup référence à lui
à la fois donc sur la couverture de
votre livre dans votre profession de foi
et dans
discours très très fréquemment est ce
que vous estimez être plus proche de son
héritage de son bilan que je prends ce
fillon aux dépens en tout cas je suis
pas très doué pour la publicité
comparative la seule chose que je puisse
vous dire c'est que j'ai clairement
inscrit mon engagement sur le chemin
tracé par nicolas sarkozy je les dis
sans ambiguïté je considère que il a
beaucoup oeuvré pour la france que même
si nous avons ici ou là de temps en
temps des désaccords connu il ne reste
pas moins qu'il a fait preuve dans cette
campagne où il a été l'objet d'attaqués
absolument inouïe d'une violence
incroyable d'un courage et d'une
solidité qui ont forcé mon admiration et
qui m'ont amené très clairement à dire
que je serai à ses côtés voilà et que
dans ce contexte la philosophie qui est
la sienne même si mon tempérament est
différent du sien sur certains sujets ou
mon point de vue et mon expérience
puisque je suis moi maire de meaux donc
c'est pas évidemment le même parcours
que le sien il n'en reste pas moins que
je les dis je me suis inscrit sur le
chemin qu'il avait tracé un point des
deux philosophies gens vous allez même
plus loin que lui sur certains points
comme la m e ou oui c'est vrai mais bon
encore une fois les temps changent et je
crois que cette nouvelle époque conduit
assez naturellement à poser les
questions claires la mc quoi l'aide
médicale d'état c'est celle qui est
versé grâce à 100% couverte le feu
c'était une couverture de soins pardon à
100% pour les pour ceux qui sont en
situation illégale dans notre pays
bon il me semble quelque chose qui
tourne pas rond dans le même temps vous
avez des millions de français qui sont
au dessus des minima sociaux et qui
n'arrivent pas à financer correctement
leurs soins de lunettes dedans auditifs
bien et donc j'ai proposé que l'on
supprime la partie de l'aide médicale
d'état qui ne correspondent pas à
l'urgence absolue aux soins des enfants
et qu'on le transférait sur un fonds qui
serait dédié à l'aide de la prise en
charge des soins pour mon ceux de dés
qui habite en france qui sont français
ou bien étrangers en situation régulière
et qui ainsi pourrez accéder à une prise
en charge meilleur pour des soins qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas bien couvert et
votre ami christian jacob lui propose
une loi pour lutter contre les fraudes
et dérapages budgétaires de cette aide
médicale un mot sur le qatar est ce que
ça vous gêne de voir le qatar vouloir
investir dans les banlieues on a
beaucoup parlé
écoutez moi j'ai dit là dessus à
plusieurs reprises je n'ai jamais été
choqué qu il
investissements étrangers en france
après la vraie question c'est s'assurer
de la traçabilité et de la finalité
donc vigilance mais en même temps ne
faisons pas un procès d'intention
systématique
voilà merci frédéric alors tout n'est
pas politique et dans votre livre jean
françois copé je le disais tout à
l'heure vous ai parlé de vous de votre
parti pris positif
vous avez montré que vous étiez positif
quant à lui long pagne femme il le
fallait parce que si on vous écoutez
voir et aux orties dépresseurs vous
parle également de votre histoire
familiale et avant d'accueillir perrine
tarneaud alexandre aquino s'est arrêté
avec quelques témoin qui vont vous
intéressé de très près sur ces quelques
pages c'est une histoire déjà évoqué en
aparté et qui introduit le manifeste
pour une droite décomplexée un héritage
qui serait à l'origine de l'engagement
politique de jean-françois copé
cette histoire est celle de son père et
de ses grands parents juifs immigrés
roumains et résistants cachés par des
justes à aubusson pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale une histoire familiale
dans la grande histoire
c'était dans la matinée ont été avertis
au père a eu juste le temps de descendre
à l'étagé du dessous pour demander à une
voisine qu'on connaissait pour ainsi
dire pas et qui était la femme d'à
tapissier de bien vouloir nous
accueillir chez elle parce que dans
quelques dans la demi-heure qui vit en
principe y aura les ss qui vont arriver
pour nous prendre
et avec une simplicité extraordinaire
elle a dit mais monsieur vous êtes chez
vous descendez ce qui est des fumant moi
cette phrase m'a toujours marqué j'étais
gosse mais et le sage est transmis
toujours à jean-françois pour lui
montrer ce que pouvait être un être
humain dans sa qualité dans sa bonté de
se passer jean françois copé écrit en
avoir puisé un amour pour la france
et l'évidence d'un engagement politique
se donne une
un pouvoir une rage d'engagement et une
rage d'engagement sous toutes ses formes
mais c'est probablement ce qui est
arrivé à jean françois copé c'est à dire
le large de comprendre la motivation à
s'engager le plaisir aussi 200 galeries
peut-être même parfois le plaisir de la
valeur reste d'entités difficile à
définir les immigrés juifs des thèmes
qui n'évoque pas directement préférant
reprendre les mots de nicolas sarkozy le
petit français de sang mais voilà à
perrine tarneaud nous a rejoint jean
françois copé françois perin
voilà c'est pourquoi vous aimez la
bagarre en écoutant boris cyrulnik
oui enfin je n'aurais pas repris le mot
de bagarres dont l'engagement oui
l'engagement il a tellement l'engagement
pour mon pays que j'explique d'ailleurs
dans mon et nous avons été éduqués par
mes parents je dis nous parce que c'est
aussi comme ma soeur et de mon frère
cadet dans l'amour de la france dans
l'idée que l'on doit à la france parce
que nous sommes vivants si je puis dire
parce qu'il est des français qui ont au
péril de leurs vies sauvées d'autres
français des justes parmi les nations
qui au même titre que les résistants que
les maquisards ont aussi fait que la
france est ce pays magnifique et que
nous aimons malgré malgré des moments
tragiques de son histoire malgré les
errements malgré les difficultés et
c'est quelque chose que je porte en moi
comme une flamme et lorsque gm faudra
compter des buts 28 mai dont vous parlez
peu dont vous avez peu parlé jusque là
en fait oui parce que les circonstances
ne s'y prêtait pas forcément vous avez
il n'y a pas de raison particulière de
raconter ça des gens que ça n'intéresse
pas forcément connaissance y prêterait
place tout simplement parce que j'ai
décidé de m'engager dans une
campagne aux côtés des militants de
l'ump pour leur proposer de m'engager
pour eux pour notre famille politique et
que j'ai pensé utile qu'à ce moment
précis il y est aussi un rendez-vous
d'authenticité
ça veut dire que vous aviez besoin de
communiquer peut-être différemment alors
sur votre image sur votre personne
non non non non ne cherchez pas là
dedans je sais comme tout à l'heure pour
le savourer ce qu'on fait de lyncheurs
et de la surenchère non non je pense que
ça des genres si c'est juste j'ai bien
trimestre des militants vous l'avez dit
sous la forme et communication etc
non je crois qu'il faut se dire les
choses très simplement chaque je pense
qu'il y a des moments dans la vie qui
sont des rendez vous de vérité et
d'authenticité je pense que les gens en
réalité ne cherche pas tellement des
photos de vous dans votre cuisine avec
la nappe à carreaux rouge et blanc et
les enfants qui gazouille ça c'est la
vie privée en tout cas c'est toujours
non elle passait jamais non jamais non
justement j'ai toujours été extrêmement
attentifs c'est la seule fois mais pour
le reste vous n'avez jamais vu mes
enfants en photo sauf peut-être
développe des photos volées que j'ai
d'ailleurs immédiatement condamné autant
que j'ai pu le faire mais j'ai toujours
protégé ma vie familiale toujours et là
dessus j'ai été d'autant plus attentifs
que pour moi ce que les gens attendent
c'est plutôt comment vous dire
un rendez-vous vraiment où les gens
veulent savoir ce qui ce qui brille en
vous voilà ce qui fait que vous avez
dans le regard l'envié de les servir
voilà de servir votre pays c'est ça qui
doit faire la différence quand est ce
que ça veut dire que jusque là vous avez
eu l'impression d'avoir été trop
caricaturé alors peut-être bon la
caricature malheureusement dans cette
société hyper médiatisée elle est notre
pain quotidien
je suis marie dont on ne parlait de moi
de manière tellement par exemple des
formes et que la joie de vos offres
emile existants monsieur emile exigences
il en écrit que je sais que je sais tout
sur tout je suis arrogant que je mets
plein des comme ça
bon la vérité je suis vachement lui dit
vous avez plus sympa que votre père oui
voilà oui oui ça c'était vraiment pas
bien de la part de ce médecin
est ce que c'est un put vous poussez
vous corriger à la remarque du médecin
je parle pas du luxe
les deux ne veut retenir de le corriger
au chien dans les caricatures
oui mais la caricature en même temps
elle est aussi liée à ce que l'on est
donc il faut il faut il faire un travail
sur soi même il faut bien sûr mais vous
savez je crois beaucoup au fait d'avoir
de vivre aussi avec des interrogations
plus qu'avec des certitudes
il faut qu'on ait des convictions mais
voilà se remette en question sans cesse
et pour ça il ya rien de mieux que le
suffrage universel c'est pour ça que moi
j'ai toujours été attaché à ma terre de
mots la ville dont je suis le maire car
c'est une ville difficile avec une
population qui est une des plus modestes
de france et qui donc est extrêmement
exigeantes à l'égard de deux de ses élus
et c'est pour ça que je me dis parfois
quand on change de deux circonscriptions
c'est pas quelque chose que je ferais
moi voilà donc à qui pensez-vous
mais ces choix attendait c'est un choix
publics donc sinon je n'aurais pas parlé
mais moi ce qui me concerne je suis
vraiment dans cette idée qui veulent des
coûts comme disait jacques chirac en
politique un nous allons tout cas pour
prendre ses responsabilités et qu'il
faut les assumer comme c'est difficile
comme quand c'est plus facile
et puis peut-être puisque vous parlez de
jacques chirac dont je parle beaucoup
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a qu'il a
vraiment contribué à merci à ma
formation et mon engagement au service
de mon pays pour lequel j'ai beaucoup de
respect j'avais retenu une de ses
formules 10 et un chef c'est fait pour
chez fait voilà quand on dirige un grand
parti politique je peux témoigner tous
les jours qu'on ne peut pas avoir
simplement la tête dans les étoiles en
attendant quand vous apporte votre
destin sur un plateau c'est tous les
jours aux côtés de ses amis militants
pour trouver les meilleures solutions
possibles voudront rejoindre le coeur
des français un élu de paris comme
françois fillon donc enfin annoncé en ce
qui me concerne ce n'est certainement
pas le choix que je ferai la violence en
politique est parfois insupportable
c'est ce que vous dites aussi dans votre
reer oui souche construire une carapace
vous parlez
dire qu'on caricature dit parfois vous
vous dites que c'est vous une prise de
distance par rapport à la violence de la
petite enfance était pas rendu compte
mais je me suis aperçu près souvent en
fait quand j'étais dans une situation
qui me blessais il pouvait m'arriver de
le masquer par un sourire voilà mais en
même temps ce qu'on vit en ce moment est
très éclairant regarder cette campagne
interne qui est une campagne qui se
terminera bien puisque le 19 novembre au
matin par définition tout le monde se
retrouvera et c'est mes copains copains
autant qu'on peut l'être mais en tout
cas
soucieux de l'intérêt général en tout
cas c'est l'esprit qui m'anime si les
militants me font confiance et me
reconduite dans mes fonctions que les
ailes maintien fait reconstruire mais en
même temps pas totalement quand même en
tout cas pour ce qui me concerne moi qui
suis tellement attachés à l'amitié
tellement attaché à la fidélité en
amitié
ce moment est un moment de vérité voilà
je vais pas vous dire le contraire mais
je vais pas passer plus de temps avec
ceux qui me déçoivent qu'avec ceux qui
au contraire sont à mes côtés et
prennent des risques en étant un des
côtés puisque si j'en crois les sondages
il en est un qui a la tête dans les
étoiles et l'autre qui a les pieds dans
le gaz de schiste donc après tous ceux
qui sont avec moi ça montre quelque part
un un vrai courage et qui est le reflet
de l'engagement militant car la
sincérité m'oblige à vous dire je suis
tous les jours en meeting et que je suis
tous les jours
bouleversé par le soutien des militants
qui est extraordinaire et qu'il reflet
de l'engagement à 1000% qui a été le
mien dans cette campagne présidentielle
aux côtés de nicolas sarkozy alors vous
parliez d'amitié en politique et aussi
de déceptions on a un partenariat avec
orange et leur application tivi tchèque
en à une question de nadia est-ce que
vous avez été blast blessé par le
ralliement de françois baroin à françois
fillon à titre politique non à titre
personnel oui un gros coup dur enfin à
titre personnel oui bien sûr quand vous
êtes en tout cas pas parler pour les
autres mais pour moi petit personnage
que vous dire les choses très simplement
jamais jamais je n'ai manqué de ma vie à
un ami
jamais parce que je ne suis pas
construit comme ça peut-être que ça un
lien aussi avec eux l'éducation que j'ai
reçue de mes parents mais pour moi la
parole donnée
la crédibilité d'une signature d'un
engagement c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important ça ne veut pas
dire que parfois on n'est pas des choix
à faire des choix déchirants vie à la
mort quand on parle de politique avait
tout à fait raison d'orientations avait
tout à fait raison mais je vous le dis
en ce qui me concerne je n'ai jamais
manqué à ma parole
voilà et que si je devais le faire ce
serait sur la base d'une explication
profonde qui serait justifié par une
rupture absolue sur des sujets vitaux
nous en sommes très loin
voilà vous êtes quand même un sarkozyste
fraîchement convertis du coup est ce que
votre sarkozysme et crédible alors je
pas passait pas comme ça que je me
définirais non non j'ai le choix groupe
à lui à loos ump à l'assemblée en juin
2010 amazon com s'est un peu chef
d'utiliser indépendant par rapport à mes
amis je suis toujours ne vous y trompez
pas je suis toujours j'ai mon histoire
il a la sienne nous avons certes
quelques points communs mais en même
temps les différences majeures puis
écoutez il a été président de la
république je suis son cadet y'a pas
voilà il ya des différences entre nous
oui bien sûr mais en même temps je vous
dis les choses
j'ai été je suis je le dis je je
l'assument j'ai été très impressionné
par la solidité dont il a fait preuve
dans cette campagne
quand même un moment présidentielle à un
moment où j'ai vu tant de personnalités
à qui il avait tant donné qu'ils ont
lâché disons les choses comme elles sont
comme d'ailleurs nous avons retrouvé à
travers les droits d'inventaire les
livres les tribunes sortie après le 6
mai je n'ai pas était de ceux là
jusqu'à la dernière minute aujourd'hui
je les fais d'autant plus avec d'autant
plus de patients que je voyais ces
milliers et milliers de françaises et de
français militants engagés à nos côtés
et du coup vous allez impression un peu
aujourd'hui qu'au tour de nicolas
sarkozy c'est un peu le bal des
tartuffes pro oui je sais pas c'est pas
forcément la force un président est
ensevelie sous les compliments pour
qu'ils soient toujours écouté pas
toujours il ya aussi des prises de
distance très intéressante à noter une
question sur la loi sur la limitation du
cumul des mandats vous êtes contre oui
bien sûr mais bien sûr je vais vous dire
c'est une belle hypocrisie tout cela je
construis la démo je pense que la
démocratie
je connais pourquoi les conclusions
j'ose pas mais la démocratie française a
ceci de positif qu'elle permet
aux élus d'avoir un mandat local et un
mandat national
c'est très très bien un député parle
d'autant plus utilement l'assemblée
nationale qu' il est le maire d'une
ville où on lui raconte les problèmes du
quotidien ou doit les résoudre
un député qui n'est pas élu qui n'est
pas maire de sa ville
mais qu'est ce qui va lui arriver demain
plus personne n'ira le voir parce que
c'est le maire de la vie rien valoir
pour les frais de logement et d'emploi
ou de sécurité s'est jamais le député 20
minutes pour deux questions qu'un député
qui exerce aussi une profession
réglementée est ce que ça on doit
limiter que c'est réglementé comme un
avocat par exemple ah d'accord
à vous écouter ça c'est autre chose la
question générale est ce que l'on doit
interdire aux députés d'avoir une autre
vie professionnelle si on ne le fait pas
et bien le permettez moi de vous dire
qu'il n'y aura plus que 100 % de
fonctionnaires sauf à considérer qu'on
ne doit pas être également fonctionnaire
est ce que les socialistes vont prendre
ce risque n'est pas sûr d'avoir derrière
tout ça et président politique très
rapidement si la loi sur le mariage
homosexuel passe vous à les marier des
couples homosexuels avaient moi je suis
opposé je les dis très clairement mais
non au mariage homosexuel je les dis en
même temps je souhaite que les propos
des uns et des autres ne soient pas car
il est rasé et crame un vrai côté on va
déjà temps de voir celle-ci arrive tu es
bon parce que bien l'intention tout ça
me paraît tellement mal rédigée qu'il y
a de quoi en débattre il ya une majorité
de gauche pour le traité budgétaire
européen à l'assemblée nationale c'est
un test réussi pour françois hollande
ah bah écoutez c'est surtout comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure une belle
hypocrisie de la part de quelqu'un qui a
fait campagne devant les français en
disant que s'il était élu il y aurait
pas traités européens
merci jean françois copé merci perrine
bonsoir à tous
et la semaine prochaine c'est jean louis
borloo qui sera notre invité bonsoir
je vous propose de commencer par la
stratégie de françois hollande alors à
l'époque où il vivait avec ségolène
royal s'était le plus discret du couple
et récemment et bien il a décidé de
présenter sa nouvelle compagne c'était
dans gala bagheri est la femme de ma vie
annonce et il élégamment en octobre
dernier
mais attention hein pas question de
poser officiellement avec sa nouvelle
compagne
c'est peut-être un détail mais pour les
vous allez voir que ça veut dire
beaucoup écouté le sur le plateau de
france 2 on va dire un mot des primaires
avec d'abord une image qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir de vous c'est cette
semaine dans un magazine people comme on
dit où vous apparaissez avec votre
compagne vous poser à ses côtés
pourquoi cette décision parce que c'est
très inhabituel
est ce qu'il faut en passer par là
lorsqu'on veut se présenter face aux
français n'avancez pas une photo posée
nous étions ensemble à la rochelle la
photo a été prise
elle est publiée voilà c'est tout vous
devez l'interview si je suis dans une
vie nouvelle heureuse
voilà il faut bien cachés mais en même
temps rien exhibé à cacher rien exhibé à
vous approuvez enfin l'âme c'est très
subtil jeudi c'est là dans ce combat du
tout à l'heure oui dit la même chose que
vous voilà subtil et que je trouve
vraiment à double tranchant la photo
elle a été prise malgré lui un an avant
mais la déclaration c'est la femme de ma
vie moi je parlais pas des tours d'avion
oui avec laquelle il a quand même eu
quatre enfants alors la réaction des
enfants s'est interrogé des femmes
autres vous autour de vous c'est
vraiment extrêmement choquant bouleversé
la femme que j'aime la femme de ma vie
on efface d'un coup et quatre enfants
bah c'est pas très malin parce que c'est
très contre-productif donc très
maladroit sur la phrase
et pourtant il n'y a pas posé un produit
ce qui était important c'était pas faire
de photos et finalement se polarise sur
la maladresse a pas posé il a décidé de
s'afficher avec une femme de dire si la
fameuse liste qui est effectivement je
trouve très maladroit parce qu'il
voulait absolument se mettre dans la
roue de la présidentielle et il faut
qu'il arrête avec cette image de meulage
qui a trompé ségolène royal et ils y
arrivent très bien par contre la
déclaration et d'une maladresse énorme
maladresse pour les femmes effectivement
qu'il va me trouver mufle en même temps
c'est la femme de ma vie ça veut dire
que dans votre sens il va dans le sens
de ce que vous dites il va se stabiliser
et maintenant c'est le message politique
c'est le message politique j'ai toujours
ce qu'on dit malgré tout à la deuxième
ou la troisième moment c'est ce qu'on
leur dise donc c'est assez honnête de
dire publiquement on est journaliste
jusqu'au bout c'est à dire même si un
jour je perds ma carte de presse
je pense que je mourrais journalistes
mais comme vous je pense donc en étant
journaliste est si proche
évidemment de françois hollande est ce
que voudront se fait des conseils pour
trouver la bonne distance avec tout ce
qui se passe en ce moment
non j'ai appris des conseils peut-être
pas mais j'ai appris moi me détendre un
peu
parce qu'effectivement je ne suis pas
passé de l'autre côté mais j'ai un pied
de chaque côté donc quand on a un pied
de chaque côté on est en déséquilibre
voilà c'est plus compliqué donc en tout
cas je suis beaucoup plus à l'aise
depuis que je n'ai plus mon émission
politique puisque j'en avais une sur
direct 8
même trois successives donc j'ai décidé
de l'arrêter de moi même et ça a été
finalement un grand soulagement
j'ai appris à me détendre un peu dit
elle que pensez vous de cette confidence
serge hefez c'est une vraie confidences
dire ça montre à quel point elle s'est
rendu compte à quel point il était
crispé et ça se voyait elle était très
mal dans cette position de se retrouver
comme ça brutalement en position de
femme de on sent bien qu'elle n'a pas
envie de ça d'abord ils sont pas mariés
alors on ne souligne pas assez mais je
crois que c'est une c'est une différence
fondamentale n'a pas l'intention de se
marier en piste il a très bien mais ça
ça repose la question de la légitimité
c'est à dire que si en plus ils ne sont
pas mariés et qu'il devient président de
la république ça va être une première
dans l'histoire de france d'avoir un
couple illégitime comme ça à la tête de
l'état donc elle a raison de dire
qu'elle ait les pieds et à pied à pied
de chaque côté et effectivement elle
représente ces femmes ces nouvelles
femmes on va dire qui jusqu'au bout vont
se battre pour leur carrière pour leur
personnalité pour leur identité sachant
que s'efface un pl c'est pas simple
quand on est à 7
c'est une personnalité profondément dual
valérie trierweiler
à l'image de tout ce que nous voyons
d'elle depuis tout à l'heure et de tout
ce que nous voyons tout le temps elle
est en effet un pied d'un côté un pied
de l'autre mais je crois que ça
correspond à une personnalité intime
d'accord c'est donc ce n'est pas assez
mans très rassurant d'accord elle
n'arrive pas à choisir parce que
finalement elle est comme ça elle veut
nous n'a la fin c'est pas possible ça
serge hefez d'être comme ça pour c'est
aussi d'être ambivalence et motif de
vouloir une chose et son contraire
enfin il ya bien un moment où la vie
vous amène à faire un certain nombre de
choix
nous ne laisserons pas des caïds
s'installer dans les quartiers de
grenoble devenu à la fois leur proie et
leurs repères et je lutterai contre tous
les trafics
toutes les mafias pas plus que je
n'accepte la délinquance financière
la fraude fiscale
pas plus
je le tolère qu'un petit caïd avec sa
bande met une cité en coupe réglée et
fassent vivre à ses habitants un enfer à
tout cela à tout cela aux délinquants
financiers aux fraudeurs aux petits
caïds
je les avertis ceux qui ont pu croire
que la loi ne les concernait pas le
prochain président les prévient la
république
oui la république vous rattrapera alors
un petit caïd avec sa bande mettre une
cité en coupe réglée lui faire vivre un
enfer comme ça à l'entendre on a
l'impression de réécouter des discours
de nicolas sarkozy alors on se doute
bien que c'est que françois hollande ya
pensé à ces références enfin on le voit
mal faire ça par hasard alors d'hamouma
iaf
selon vous